[Musique]
bon bah
bienvenue pierre rené lemas bonjour
aitana ses invités ça va ça va très bien
est ce que vous diriez vous même que
vous êtes un homme engagé
oui oui franchement oui c'est
l'engagement
l'engagement c'est une partie de la vie
quoi c'est quelque part je sais pas
comment on peut dire c'est les promesses
qu'on se fait à soi même
oui voilà après faut les tenir alors on
va essayer de savoir d'où ça vient moi
je me souviens quand j'étais enfant
j'allais chanter la marseillaise devant
le monument aux morts et il semble que
ça m'a donné l'idée de la nation est ce
que l'idée de l'état ça se forge où ça
ça se rencontrent moi je pense que ça se
rencontrent oui c'est toujours un peu
impudique de parler de soi mais moi
j'étais un petit garçon à alger pendant
la guerre d'algérie
et là vous aviez les drapeaux français
partout des manifestations je me
souviens même un jour je crois avoir vu
le général de gaulle dans une
manifestation gens qui criaient vive la
france bon et là vous avez quelque chose
qui est un petit peu plus fort que vous
qui vous donne envie
en tous les cas c'est comme ça que je
vois les choses qui vous donne envie de
vous engager
donc ça veut dire que c'est quelque
chose qui à l'extérieur et qui est plus
grand que soi
ouais moi c'est ce que je crois alors
évidemment ça doit rencontrer des choses
au fond de soi qu'on a appris ce qu'on
connaît qu'on vit on est fébrile de
commandes hier de vibration d'une
certaine manière bon mais je pense que
c'est une rencontre voilà engagement
c'est une rencontre
est ce que ça peut être aussi une image
qu'on a je crois que votre grand père
était secrétaire de mairie
c'est vrai est-ce que ça participe de sa
way sûrement plutôt le côté anciens
combattants ce des secrétaires de mairie
ça me disait pas grand chose pour
c'est plutôt la moustache de l'ancien
combattant de la guerre de 14 voiliers
que j'ai vu quand j'étais quand j'étais
petit puis c'est souvent une histoire
familiale c'est une histoire de milieux
chez moi vous voyez on dans mon petit
monde dans ma famille on est très
gaulliste très patriote donc vous être
dans une espèce de de bain comme ça qui
vous donne envie de servir l'état
donc c'est aussi une culture oui je
crois veut dire que vos enfants ils ont
le sens de l'état ça veut dire que mes
enfants tout le calme bien état ils
connaissent l'état
oui ça leur dit quelque chose la france
l'état la république faisait ses grands
mots qui sont devenus un petit peu
désuet aujourd'hui on nous tue les dire
c'est des mots qui connaissent qu'ils
leur disent quelque chose là bas et ils
sont contents d'aller vous parlez de
monument aux morts si à l'occasion moi
j'ai fait ça beaucoup quand j'étais
préfet allait déposer des gerbes au
monument aux morts fait partie du métier
bon il venait volontiers parce que
c'était un moment quoi est-ce que c'est
un moment de communautés un moment où
vous savez quand vous êtes en région
autrefois en disant province il paraît
qu'on n'a plus le droit d en province
moi j'aime bien recommencer quand vous
êtes en région
vous avez des petits moments de
communion républicaine par exemple vous
avez la mairie d'un petit bled du côté
de l'aisne qui va être inaugurée vous
avez de l'autre côté de la france un
centre sportif un thé à la vie et au
moment où vous avez coupé le ruban
vous avez toujours des gens qui sont
invités qui viennent à des notables mais
vous avez aussi un grand concours de
population les gens arrivent ils adorent
et il adore pas uniquement à cause du
vin blanc mousseux combat à la fin c'est
tiède et puis puis c'est pas dur et
champagne en général c'est pas du
champomy non plus mais ils viennent y
viennent parce que c'est un petit moment
d'harmonie républicaine le service de
l'état y rencontrent parfois la violence
on va revenir en arrière le 6 février 98
en est encore un grand serviteur de
l'état va mourir claude erignac se
rendait avec son épouse à un concert
il venait de descendre de sa voiture
lorsque deux personnes peut être plus se
sont précipités sur lui
ils ont tiré plusieurs coups de feu dans
le dos de claude erignac
claude erignac est le premier haut
fonctionnaire de l'état assassiné dans
l'île les préfets reignac c'était votre
ami c'était mon patron d'abord j'étais
au ministère des départements
d'outre-mer et ça me ça même avec
beaucoup d'années de retard c'était mon
patron c'est devenu mon ami et vous
voyez avant ce moment tragique là qu'on
a vu
je l'avais eue au téléphone oui et il
m'avait dit tu sais
il en avait un peu à ckoi c'est juste à
la juste avant juste avant il m'avait
dit bon voilà on avait parlé un petit
peu tous les deux il ya aujourd'hui
encore à ma place cinq ans mais voilà ça
a été le cas quelques années après puis
bon bah ce soir jouer au théâtre
donc pour moi ça a été un événement
tragique à la fois du point de vue
national pour tout le monde mais c'est
un événement tragique du point du
personnage sa une place singulière dans
votre vie ah oui oui oui oui parce que
c'est des préfet mort dans l'exercice de
leurs fonctions des prêts faits
représenter la république qu'ils vivent
ça dans leur chair est là bas n'a pas
tant que ça
vous savez dans notre panthéon de
fonctionnaires de l'état on à jean
moulin et puis on à eyrignac et erignac
était un homme à la fois rigoureux
intègre en même temps sympathique et
joueur de tennis
moi il me manque beaucoup c'est très
singulier dans votre parcours pierre
rené lemas combien la violence et l'état
sont mêlés
la violence c'est pas la première fois
que vous la rencontrez quand le préfet
erignac était abattu vous l'avez déjà
rencontrées en 62 votre père est la
cible de l'om
il prend deux balles il laissé pour mort
c est vous même vous allez échappé à un
attentat quand vous même vous serez
préfet de corse
on va tirer à la roquette dans votre
numéro l'engagement ça va jusque là en
tous les cas j'ai appris ça de mon père
moi c'est que
comment dire ça sans être impudique
mon père était un homme engagé tu es un
homme engagé
oui gaulliste engagés à un moment
difficile de l'histoire de france qui
était la guerre d'algérie vers la fin de
la guerre d'algérie après que général de
gaulle et annoncé un référendum chose
qu'on appelait l'algérie algérienne à
l'époque c'était vocabulaire acquis qui
a l'air très anciens bon il s'était
engagé était candidat aux élections dans
la casbah d'alger voilà et moi je fais
partie de ceux qui ont un prix d'or par
an en tous les cas j'ai appris ça de mon
père c'est que l'engagement
comment dire on s'engage on s'engage pas
jamais obligé de s'engager mais si on
s'engage faut aller au bout
c'est ça qui cache votre je vous connais
un peu vous avez souvent le sourire
toujours l'oeil qui frise est en fait
vous êtes très grave vous savez que le
service de l'état c'est quelque chose de
très grave puisqu'elle ça va jusqu'à
mourir
c'est ça que vous cachez où je peux
aussi je le cache
je trouve que oui c'est vrai que dans la
vie il faut pas passer son temps à faire
la tête là où se sentir soi même un
personnage essentiel ou importants n'ont
en revanche oui je crois que le service
de l'état c'est quelque chose de très
sérieux moi j'ai toujours été très agacé
par ce des serviteurs de l'état c'est
devenu un peu à la mode depuis quelques
années au fond qu'ils prennent c'est
avec une désinvolture apparente moi je
déteste cette désinvolture l'état c'est
une charge qu'on dit charge charge ça
veut dire un poids un poids au sens
physique c'est quelque chose qu'on va
sur les épaules lui
voilà je crois qu'il faut l'assumer se
dire que alors après c'est bien c'est
mal on fait son boulot comme il faut pas
est à venir c'est pas un boulot c'est
une mission que c'est quelque chose
qu'on accepte au service des autres et
vous acceptez vous jusqu'à je sais pas
l'ultime violence si on pose la question
à froid comme ça on y danse que vous
acceptez jusqu'à l'ultime duel ans je
sais pas répondre je sais pas répondre
parce que c'est au moment où les choses
se passent qu'on sait si oui ou non on
est capable d'aller jusqu'au bout et je
veux ce serait une immense présomption
de dire ses vieilles questions que se
posaient ma génération qui était
j'aurais fait quoi en 40
je suis incapable de répondre à cette
question j'aurais fait quoi en cas où je
serais une présomption incroyable mais
je pense que à un petit niveau et tout
au long de ce que j'ai pu vivre en
quelques années comme ça en quelques
décennies maintenant aux services de
l'état d'un celi petit question qu'on se
pose comme ça si j'osais utilisé une
expression de mes enfants je dirais sans
faire le malin ça rend heureux de servir
l'état
oui oui elle a par moments c'est grave
par moments c'est lourd comme je disais
tout à l'heure
en même temps c'est bien parce que comme
on dit c'est pas abstrait de servir
l'état ne s'est pas du tout abstrait
vous avez quand vous êtes préfet par
exemple dans un dans un département
picardie en lorraine j'ai pas où j'étais
sous préfet en dordogne
vous prenez des décisions auprès des
décisions en général pas tout seul avec
des collaborateurs
et puis en parlant et des tas de gens
les élus les syndicats les patrons
d'entreprises que sage les assauts ce
pont et puis à un moment donné votre
décision à lui à concrètes vous dites
moi il vit les choses
vous êtes à ce que l'état celle à
l'endroit entre la décision et
l'application d'un champ et moi je pense
que c'est ça le l'un des problèmes de
l'état aujourd'hui c'est cette distance
d'ailleurs vous prenez une décision et
puis et puis le temps est interminable
entre le moment où la décision est prise
et le moment où ces mises en oeuvre ça
je veux donner un exemple je me suis
pendant longtemps occupé d'habitat
social de construction de logements
sociaux voilà des métiers différents
entre le moment où vous décidez de faire
une rénovation d'un quartier en
difficulté et le moment où les gens vont
pouvoir aménager il se passe une
éternité découleront c'est l'éternité
entre le moment où la maman une
poussette et le moment où son grand
garçon va sortir du lycée
c'est un de leurs deux gîtes mais c'est
ça vous avez une image très précise de
ce que c'est que l'état vous le décrivez
est cette image on l'a retrouvé regardez
là
colombet c'est donc le corner du général
pourquoi cette image pour vous c'est
l'image de l'état bah écoutez moi j'ai
eu le sentiment voyage était avec des
amis on était sur le toit d'une
d'une grange vous êtes allé assez loin
du général mais ça a été compliqué
derrière de trouver un train aussi émis
à plusieurs on a beaucoup marché et on a
fini par trouver une place où j'étais je
sais pas j'avais vingt ans peut-être
on était sur le toit d'une sur le toit
d'une grange ce moment où le cercueil
très simple du général de gaulle
recouvert du drapeau du drapeau bleu
blanc rouge passe pour aller vers ce
petit cimetière avec juste une croix
rien moi j'ai eu l'impression d'avoir
cette vision de l'état voilà pour moi
l'état l'état c'était un peu ça c'est
de gaulle
chef de l'état prenant des décisions
quand plus personne ne veut les prendre
assumant ses décisions et puis voilà et
plus profondément que ça assumant des
décisions dans un moment où la houle de
l'histoire le ballet lui aussi il ne
façonne pas seulement l'histoire
il est aussi me jouer de cette histoire
et en même temps il prend des décisions
donc c'est c'est ça que j'ai trouvé
totalement bouleversant à l'époque
non j'ai un très grand souvenir de ce
moment là c'est vrai j'avais pas vu ces
images depuis très très longtemps très
longtemps
il ya un autre moment beaucoup plus
proche de nous tous et de vous en
particulier qui ressemble singulièrement
à ce que vous venez nous dire il va
falloir que vous vous concentriez on va
juste écouter mais le pouvoir
l'exercice du pouvoir les lieux du
pouvoir et les rites du pouvoir ne l'ont
jamais fait perdre ma lucidité ni sur
moi même ni sur la situation car je dois
agir et aujourd'hui je suis conscient
des risques que ferait courir une
démarche la mienne qui ne rassemblerait
pas l'agent largement autour d'elle
aussi j'ai décidé de ne pas être
candidat à l'élection présidentielle
je me souviens bien de ce moment j'étais
c'est un moment singulier
le président de la république donc moi
j'étais plus un de ses collaborateurs
j'étais à l'époque directeur de la
caisse des dépôts m'avait invité avec
bien d'autres personnes pour une remise
de décorations il m'a décoré voilà il y
avait deux tableaux de genre tout le
monde s'est levé
vous imaginez des noms du rouge de
l'elysée il faut imaginer les huissiers
avec leur petit coussin sur lesquels
vous avez la croix du mérite ou celle de
la légion d'honneur voilà et puis juste
après la cérémonie commence y avoir un
bruit ça qu'il présent la république va
parler dans le petit studio de la rue de
l'elysée vous savez que l'elysée un
petit studio de télévision ou la presse
et parfois reçu voilà et donc on est
allé avec quelques amis les amis du
début du début du quinquennat françois
hollande le regarder à la télévision bon
tout est bien on avait compris quelque
chose quoi mais vous ne savez pas non je
sais pas mais non je savais pas et on
entendu ça le président hollande annoncé
ça et c'est vrai que ça a été un moment
étrange parce que quand on était
on est et on avait dit des sentiments
mélangés on était un peu triste un peu
furieux
un mélange des deux fois la crise qu'il
n'y avait pas furieux qu'ils ne
voulaient pas dit avant non presse qu'il
y avait pas furieux qu'ils y aillent pas
qu'il fallait pour est ce que vous les
mots que vous disiez à propos du général
de gaulle vous pourriez exactement les
coller sur françois hollande peut-être
que vous ne le pensez pas j'en sais rien
mais est-ce que renoncer ça n'est pas
aussi s'engager et quand ils dansent sur
cette question se pose
je pense que vous avez raison renoncé
c'est une décision c'est une décision
c'est une décision d'un engagement
c'est un engagement une forme
d'engagement c'est un angle c'est l'âge
qui a dû être
je pense que c'est douloureux je pense
pas du tout que ce soit lâché non je
pense une décision douloureuse c'est une
décision personnelle at reste très
compliqué c'est très compliqué pour
quelqu'un qui a été conseillé de porter
un jugement sur une décision on la prend
quant à elle savait le chef de l'état ça
fait partie des choses que tout le monde
dit qui parfois m'exaspère parce que cdc
des lieux communs mais profondément
c'est vrai le chef de l'état c'est la
clé de voûte des institutions se nomme
deux seuls oui c'est un homme seul
j'ai été un de ses principaux
conseillers quand j'étais auprès du à
l'elysée vous avez téléchargé dernier je
peux témoigner quand j'étais socata
charles de l'elysée que le président
n'aurait plus qu'à la fin des fins est
un homme seul poumon lui donne un fils
en conseil il écoute il est bienveillant
ou agacés jeu dépend des moments
mais à la fin des fins il est seul et
une décision comme celle qu'il a prise
la ligne décision profondément
personnelle profondément solitaire
personne ne peut se mettre à la place
d'un président de la république qui dit
j'y vais j'y vais pas vous partagez avec
françois hollande le goût de la
normalité vous vous dites que c'est
grotesque de confondre soi même avec la
fonction qu'on a donc non n'est pas le
secrétaire général de l'elysée c'est une
fonction non on n'est pas préfet c'est
une fonction moi je suis pierre rené
lemas et j'ai une fonction vous détestez
ceux qui confondent la fonction et eux
mêmes
je trouve ça un peu triste sont quand
même nombreux les serviteurs de l'état
au sérieux non je suis là je sais bien
je sais bien oui je souviens c'est mais
vous savez je suis très modeste et à
dire j'ai peut-être confondu les haines
vous avez simplement avec l'expérience
le temps et puis j'ai fait beaucoup de
métier dans le monde de l'administration
à paris en province dans des cabinets
ministériels auprès de l'elysée dans
j'ai fait des tas de choses et donc on
finit quand même par faire la différence
entre soi et la fonction alors ça veut
pas dire faut pas s'impliquer
on parle d'engagement bien sûr
l'engagement ça veut dire on y est tout
en assure mais en même temps il ya un
texte célèbre de peggy je crois qui est
dans une manif un jour je crois que
c'est à l'occasion de l'installation la
la statue de la république place de la
république mais les historiens bombe
reprendre ses peut-elle statut de la
nation place de la nation joliet à la
fin du siècle dernier du siècle d'avant
il dit cette chose extraordinaire il dit
j'étais dans la manifestation et en même
temps j'avais envie d'être sur le
trottoir regarder la manifestation
passer ces jolies tenues comment faire
comment faire les deux à la fois quand
on est au fond services de l'état on est
dans la manif quoi si j'ose dire par les
temps qui courent mais on avance quoi on
y est on fait des choses temps en temps
on a envie aussi d'être un peu sur le
côté et de se dire voilà je ne suis pas
que le personnage est ce que vous pensez
pas que le mystère un peu lors à un peu
nébuleuse ne serait-ce que le
vocabulaire les visiteurs du soir les
grands serviteurs de l'état et c est ce
que ça ne participe pas de la défiance
moi je crois qu'on peut tout dire d'une
manière simple c'est quelque chose que
je professe si josien depuis extrêmement
longtemps on peut tout dire simplement
on n'est pas obligé d'utiliser des
grands mots
parfois les grands mots sont utiles ils
renvoient des choses plus grandes que
soit parlé tout à l'heure de la
république de la nation des choses comme
ça la justice sociale c'est les grands
mots service public c'est des grands
mots qui qui renvoie des choses qui
rompt contenu du rheu et puis dans
l'exercice de d'un exercice de ses
fonctions
je pense qu'il faut dire les choses
simplement regarder aujourd'hui c'est
très compliqué pour nos concitoyens
d'avoir une idée des choix économiques
que font les gouvernements successifs
c'est très compliqué si vous dites à
quelqu'un dans la rue si je dis à ma
famille à mes copains j'ai des copains
qui sont pas dans la haute
administration
si je la dis est ce que tu es plutôt
favorables à la politique de la fois la
politique de la demande
il me regarde avec des grands yeux alors
que ça peut se dire simplement mais si
on la dit simplement où ça s'est perdu
puisque vous parlez de cette espèce de
l'euroland d'excusés nerf du jeu je
crois qu'on a su le dire prenait les
prenez les les grands discours que plus
personne ne lit aujourd'hui parce que
c'est un peu pompeux c'est une autre
manière de parler
la troisième et même de la 4ème
république au fond on pouvait dire les
choses avec un sujet un verbe complément
et sans avoir le sentiment de déchoir
je pense qu'il ya une depuis plusieurs
années sans doute depuis quinzaine
d'années une vingtaine d'années au fond
nous sommes dans le temps des experts et
les généralistes ont envie d'être des
experts mais les généralistes sont pas
tous des experts est-ce que c'est mal
d'être généraliste pas du tout on est
expert d'un peu tout alors vous me direz
on est aussi expert de rien du tout
parfois mais moi je pense qu'on peut
dire les choses assez simplement où
est-elle utile le plus utile aujourd'hui
est ce qu'on est plus utile quand on est
à l'intérieur d'un cabinet ou quand on
est à la tête d'une association quand on
est dans l'initiative privée ou quand on
est dans le ventre de la bête
je pense que
ça se présente pas en termes de plus ou
moins je pense que c'est 2-2 manière
assez différente de se sentir citoyen
d'être citoyen quand vous êtes au sein
de l'état pardon je vous arrête on a
l'impression que l'état il est un peu
paralysé quand même et que ce qu'il faut
avancer les choses
ils sont quand même sur le terrain c'est
on a quand même ce sentiment là parce
que l'énergie elle vient de la société
civile est pas un job j'aurais du mal à
dire l'inversé puisque je choisissais ce
que c'est aujourd'hui et que je me suis
engagé dans la société civile oui au
service des gens qui sont très éloignées
de l'emploi au service de ce qu'on
appelle maintenant l'économie sociale où
l'économie solidaire donc jugé pas de
limites
mais en même temps si j'ose encore dire
en même temps qu'ils aient des âmes est
connoté le l'état le service de l'état
les fonctionnaires au sein de la machine
de l'état au sein du ventre de la bête
comme moody's enter sont des gens qui
sont beaucoup plus engagé qu'on ne le
croit donc beaucoup plus on a une vision
qui est une vision au fond très très de
sociologie politique ou d'économie
simplifiée ont fini on va finir par
penser un jour que l'état c'est une
addition de coûts les frais généraux de
la nation
tous ces fonctionnaires ça coûte cher à
quoi ça sert
les technocrates les technocrates ou
devrait viser les ronds-de-cuir les gens
qui n'ont pas de visage
la réalité c'est que tous ces
fonctionnaires là qui sont parfois les
fonctionnaires très modestes ont très
envie
ils savent la république à leur niveau
alors on le sait pour ce qu'est un
visage le pompier l'infirmière le
policier le gendarme ça on sait mais
tous ceux qui sont dans les ministères
et qui passent pas leur temps à faire
des cocottes en papier
ou ajuster leur lorgnons comme dans les
romans de séraphin de viable je crois
que ils sont aussi engagés dans une
démarche citoyenne beaucoup plus qu'on
le croit alors l'engagement associatif
ou oui ça j'ai pas de doute parce que ça
s'additionne c'est ça vous êtes en train
de manière celle en cinq jours c'est
l'un plus l'autre je voudrais que si
vous aviez la gentillesse de me lire
cette phrase parce que je la trouve très
belle et je pense qu'elle vous parle
être de gauche c'est d'abord penser le
monde puis son pays puis ses proches qui
soit être de droite celle inverse
j'adore j'aime beaucoup la phrase est de
le gore c'est vrai ouais je pense que
c'est très vrai je pense que c'est très
vrai de très près moi je ne suis jamais
engagé dans un parti mais j'assume
depuis toujours d'être de gauche
d'ailleurs corps encore mais de gauche
comme jacques chirac ou de gauche comme
qui ça c'est très intéressant au final
oui vous savez que jacques chirac a même
été travailliste à sa demande à
l'oublier ça et manière de droite ou de
gauche de servir l'état
vous savez pour un fonctionnaire la
première règle c'est d'abord d'être
l'eic si j'ose dire
thomas qui les a droit à tous qu'il est
à gauche ce qui doit être laïque de la
xe pas dire notre est engagé au service
de l'état c'est quelque chose qui est
supérieur à lui et il est à bas l'état
il est conduit par un cocher qui tient
le cheval vers la droite ou qui tire le
cheval vers la gauche et le
fonctionnaire d'état y suis moi c'est
pas un mercenaire
c'est un acteur dans un monde laïc alors
après oui vous avez un regard un peu
différent vous avez à regarder quand
j'étais préfet il m'est arrivé beaucoup
de gérer les problématiques d'ordre
public par exemple sur les
problématiques tour du pipeau qu'une
manière de gauche ont d'ailleurs de
droite je serai très simplificateurs
mais je pense que on peut avoir un
regard plus ou moins bienveillant sur la
manière de faire je veux dire des choses
très simples sur une manifestation par
exemple
une des règles de base core qui ont
appris les anciens et que je crois
toujours juste c'est qu'il faut toujours
laisser une porte ouverte
il faut que les manifestants puissent
partir à un moment ou un autre il faut
qu'ils puissent partir doucement ou se
sauver on n'enferme pas on n'enferme pas
le sens de l'état on l'a plus ou moins
est ce que vous savez reconnaître un
grand homme d'état et je vous assure que
ça me fait mal de vous dire un grand
homme d'état parce que il devrait on
devrait devrait y avoir beaucoup plus de
grandes femmes d'état mais le mot ne
sonne pas ce qui est d'ailleurs raconte
quelque chose
est ce que vous connaissez aujourd'hui
de grands hommes d'état dans le paysage
politique français
le grand homme aux deux grandes femmes
d'état au sens où je considère que c'est
au service de l'art
de l'état jeholet moi j'ai des
référentiels qui sont vraiment très
anciens maintenant mais justement c'est
moderne quelques la mer dans les
moddeurs c'est à dire j'ai du mal à
trouver un richelieu j'ai du mal à
trouver un clemenceau j'ai du mal à
trouver un de gaulle nulle part ni à
gauche ni à droite j'ai du mal mais je
me trompe peut-être parce que vous savez
il arrive aussi que le grand homme
d'état
je crois que c'est de gaulle qui disait
ça c'est à la fois une volonté croisées
avec les circonstances la volonté
beaucoup l'ont les circonstances pas
toujours et après il faut être à la
hauteur des cerveaux sens et c'est au
croisement des deux vous savez c'est le
clemenceau jusqu'à 1,1 clemenceau lattre
comme c'était à la mode de la tia
quelques années et j'ai beaucoup
d'admiration pour clemenceau avec les
manceaux avant d'être le clemenceau qui
marchait dans les monts delà des
tranchées de la première guerre mondiale
c'est quelqu'un qui a été attaquée qui a
attaqué cas mam était au milieu de
l'histoire en peu sordide dont il est
sorti mais voilà ça n'a pas toujours été
un très grand peuple
c'est devenu un très grand homme donc je
pense qu'il faut laisser prenez prenez
blum peut pas prendre mendes parce que
tout le monde prend mendes on n'est pas
non mais voilà les femmes des nains je
ne sais pas peut-être il sera peut-être
un grand homme d'état j'en sais rien je
ne sais pas encore où on est parti de 62
et on arrive là si c'était à refaire
pierre rené lemas alors c'est compliqué
ça comme qu'est ce donc comme question
si c'était à refaire j'ai d'abord vous
dire moi y'a des tas de choses dans la
vie que j'ai envie de faire et que je
ferai et peut-être que j' aurais fait
moi j'aurais adoré écrire des livres
faire du cinéma qui est qui et qui est
la passion une des passions ma vie
voilà j'ai plein de choses à faire dans
la vie alors peut-être que je n'aurais
pas fait ça j'aurais j'ai été
journaliste pendant un temps ma vie
j'aurais adoré ça aussi voilà mais tout
compte fait si c'était à refaire je
crois quand même que je referais la même
chose
merci beaucoup perdent m merci beaucoup
merci invités
[Musique]